I don't take many vacations but I do
travel all the time to work and to work
from I would rather change my
backgrounds and change my environments
but still run the same day more or less
and that gives me a lot of the stimulus
that a vacation normally does just the
change of scenery actual true days off
we tend to Layla and I take when we need
rest and so if we feel burnt out we will
take the day to recharge and then we
will work but we work as much as we can
not because we have to but because it's
what we enjoy doing most when we rest
it's what we enjoy second most to
working we only keep our work to rest
ratio based on our personal needs